hey I'm [ __ ] for transparent replicant
hayyan specimens payers Pierce bench mr.
Paris for his pants pants pants pants
pants pants pants pants pants pants but
there's business that's best fans [ __ ]
miss miss miss miss miss miss business
bands forever banned trans to peasants
and Swiss businessman spats
hey everyone my name is Matt bellows I
and this is whine about it a weekly
video series where I get drunk at my
desk and complain about stuff on this
week's episode reasons wearing pants is
the absolute worst is the only reason we
have to do this is because society tells
us we have to do this and if enough of
us band together and decide we don't
want to wear pants when we leave the
house anymore we won't have to do it we
can put an end to this once and for all
but first let's drink it doesn't even
affect me anymore I'm dead inside
I'm just a vessel okay all right first
of all vine pants is one big cruel
painful joke I haven't spent four years
in college to waste my precious [ __ ]
time and money squeezing my sweaty hams
into a [ __ ] venus thigh trap tryna
pants is basically a [ __ ] mind game
you got to take off your shoes you're
hungry you're confused your face is
streaked with dry tears and you don't
even remember when you started crying
all the squeezed into a piece of fabric
that measures how much fatter you are
than the last time you tried on pants
last time I tried on pants they had to
send in a fireman to rescue me he had to
bring in those big scissors but they
used to cut ribbons next leaf can hurt
so our bodies weren't designed to be
wrapped in [ __ ] like Tupperware do
you think cavemen wore pants no they
didn't is they didn't live in a society
where the man told him to wrap him up
they had to go out and hunt and kill
their own food and they didn't get
stopped by piece of fabric
Chaffin um right in the grundle you
can't do anything with an itchy chafed
grundle good luck hunting down a
mastodon with an itchy chafed grundle
that's why cavemen
we're so successful this they didn't
have pants holding them back
that's all pants are there just
obstacles pants are designed to hold you
back from achieving all your hopes and
dreams also pants are basically just
like furnaces they're just tiny body
ovens out of high heat you know what
your thighs need freedom that's what
they need Liberty Thomas Jefferson wrote
the Declaration of Independence you
think he wore pants I don't think so he
were those tiny little white leggings
that all the men wore then and I bet I
was liberating his [ __ ] he just walks
wherever he wants flap it around this
little Thomas Jefferson take out next
you can't can spill anything with pants
on what if I'm eating a delicious hot
melty chocolate lava cake with ice cream
and I spill that [ __ ] everywhere like I
do every time it's ridiculous but
society expects me to wear something
that I'm guaranteed to [ __ ] ravage
with steaming hot fudge my pants are
just a mosaic of all the mistakes that
I've made I don't need that kind of
documentation in my life if I weren't
wearing pants I just scrape all those
mistakes away with my little spoon I've
done it I've dropped ice cream right up
right on my hot loin
I just scrape it off a spoon scrape it
right off also pants are weak you know
many pants have ripped right open
because they couldn't withstand the
strength of my mighty thunderous thighs
all of them every pant I've ever faced
has been destroyed in the face of my
powerful thunders I got into a cab once
and bam ripped right open right near my
chandelier also everybody who wears
pants is the [ __ ] worst you know wore
pants Hitler Stalin Randy Jackson from
American Idol you know Jenna wear pants
Gandhi the PO you're the most important
anti pants advocate of our time Beyonce
[ __ ] Knowles Beyonce doesn't need Pam
to do [ __ ] you think Beyonce's gonna let
pants stop her we're running the [ __ ]
world
I don't think so and finally taking off
pants at the end of the day is a [ __ ]
nightmare ceiling it's like opening up a
hot sweaty ham that's been sitting in
the Sun all day and watching it slide
out of its wet plastic wrapper and all
this because society is still stuck in
the eighteen hundreds well guess what
its 2015 we don't have to take it
anymore so take off your pants look
Barack Obama right in his face and tell
him sir I don't have to wear pants if I
don't want to play I want to go outside
with my bare thighs we can do it yes we
can so take the pledge and say no to
pants all right everybody thank you for
watching this week as always you can
find our videos every week on
whineaboutit.tumblr.com and my page
which is facebook.com slash BuzzFeed Mac
and that's it that's everything thank
you for watching
Oh God
oh good tell me in the rulebook where it
says I gotta wear pants every day when I
walk into this office tell me that in
your loss
boom you just got Law School Legally
Blonde look it up